Роман вже три роки, як переїхав до Києва з окупованого Донецька,
проте лише зараз вирішив таки здобути вищу освіту.
Він закінчив школу в 2014 році, тож тепер,
як і решта дітей та молоді з ОРДЛО, має право на особливі умови вступу.
Зокрема без зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання.
Після того, як я поїхав з Донецька, якось непросто жити насправді,
треба на роботу влаштовуватись, квартиру знімати, бо жити ніде,
якось крутитися треба. А ЗНО - це витрата і грошей,  і часу, якого у мене немає.
Тож це в принципі зручно, я хоч зможу вступити і вивчитись.
Роман складає вступний іспит до Таврійського університету імені Вернадського,
який у 2016 році переїхав з окупованого Криму до Києва.
Донедавна це був один зі ста дев’яти вишів, які приймали дітей з окупованих територій
за спрощеною процедурою вступу.
Та цього року Верховна Рада обмеження на перелік вишів скасувала,
тож тепер абітурієнти з Криму та Донбасу можуть подавати документи
до будь-якого закладу вищої освіти.
Зроблено це було у розпал проведення ЗНО
і викликало у суспільстві не лише схвалення.
В Таврійському університеті, де 70% студентів -
це випускники шкіл з ОРДЛО, такі зміни називають непродуманими.
Це рішення було необачним. Хто під час вступної кампанії змінює правила гри?
Ми сіли в потяг Київ-Львів, а нам у дорозі кажуть: ви знаєте, графік змінився,
все змінилося і ми зараз уже не у Львів поїдемо, а кудись в Одесу їдемо.
Так не робить ніхто. Як наслідок і батьків ввели в оману, і дітей.
Не просто й вишам. Адже після розпорядження Верховної Ради
в екстреному порядку ті мають забезпечити вступну кампанію для дітей з ОРДЛО.
В Київському національному університеті імені Тараса Шевченка
облаштували чотири гарячі лінії для спілкування з абітурієнтами з Криму та Донбасу
та запровадили електронну подачу документів на вступ через сайт.
Вони часто дзвонять. Вони в більшості зазначають, що вони
живучи там, на Донбасі або в Криму,
регулярно їздили через кордон, щоб вчитись в наших закладах освіти.
В тому числі, навіть на бакалавраті.
Тобто не лише школярі, ми зараз говоримо про бакалаврат,
вони вчилися в українських закладах освіти і хотіли би продовжувати навчання.
Тому нині постійно дзвонять і шукають шляхи, як продовжити свою освітню траєкторію тут.
Суспільне значення цих змін дуже велике, і людям це потрібно.
Загалом спрощену процедуру вступу до українських вишів
для дітей з окупованих територій Верховна Рада запровадила ще в 2016 році.
Згідно з нею, вступникам не треба здавати ЗНО, мати атестат та український паспорт.
Необхідно лише зареєструватись у спеціальних освітніх центрах
"Крим-Україна" і "Донбас-Україна" та скласти три іспити:
з української мови, історії України та вступний іспит,
залежно від обраної спеціальності та вишу.
Народна депутатка та в минулому заступниця міністра освіти Інна Совсун розповідає,
що до 2020 року переліки закладів освіти
були обмеженими і окремими для Криму та Донбасу.
Це були переважно переміщені виші на півдні та сході країни.
Те, що обмеження скасували, впевнена Совсун,
позитивний сигнал для дітей з окупованих територій.
До цього ми казали: ви - наші громадяни,
але ось є перелік закладів, куди ви можете вступати, а всі інші - ні.
Ось це було дискримінаційно. Вони через це відчували, що їх тут не хочуть бачити.
Зараз дозволили вступати в будь-які заклади.
Ми хочемо, щоб ці діти приїздили навчатись в Україну,
це наш місточок, це підтримання зв'язку з окупованими територіями
і політично це правильний підхід України, працювати з цією молоддю,
щоб мати можливість поступово повертати і людей, і територію.
Крім того, депутати змінили і розподілення
бюджетних місць для дітей з окупованих територій.
Якщо раніше держава гарантувала безкоштовне навчання для 2500 кримчан,
то тепер в цю квоту входять і діти з Донбасу.
Тож діти з окупованих територій, які не здають ЗНО,
аж ніяк не забирають бюджетні місця у решти українських вступників,
наголошує правозахисниця Альона Луньова.
А саме такі фейки масово поширюють в соцмережах  окремі депутати та деякі ЗМІ.
Чому так відбувається і чому депутати можуть дозволяти собі розпалювати ворожнечу
до мешканців окупованих територій і назвати їх дуже необґрунтовано
різними негарними епітетами?
Говорити, що це діти "сепарів" і що вони нас вбивали, стріляли, а тут тобі їм освіта.
І плюс розповсюджувати ці фейки, що бойовик так званої "ДНР"
поїхав вступати через заклади освіти.
Це розповсюджували і деякі ЗМІ в перші дні після прийняття закону.
Це, звичайно, недопустимо,це те, що розпалює ворожнечу. А ми хочемо єдності.
Нинішні випускники - це діти, яким на початок окупації було всього десять років.
Тож вони вже з п’ятого класу не вивчали ані українську мову й літературу
ані історію України.
Відповідно, з кожним роком дедалі важче інтегрувати таких дітей
в український освітній процес, кажуть в Таврійському університеті.
Тут, наприклад, для першокурсників збільшили кількість годин
на вивчення предметів, які в окупації вони не вивчали.
Вони трохи підзабули мову, бо уклон робився на
вивчення "Всесвітньої історії" не "Історії України".
І коли приїжджають сюди, то зіштовхуються з проблемою.
Їм доводиться все згадувати.
Багато хто працює з репетиторами з тих, хто вступає.
І коли вони сюди приїжджають, у них, в принципі, питань не виникає.
Є проблема з вимовою.
Коли заповнюємо декларації, діти бува питають: як це звучить по-українськи.
Тобто вони не можуть перекласти.
Особливий підхід до дітей з окупованих територій варто запроваджувати
й іншим освітнім закладам, радять в Таврійському університеті.
Окрім того, вступна кампанія в цьому виші найдовша - понад п'ять місяців -
і триває до 23 жовтня.
Такі терміни не випадкові, адже влітку окупаційна влада
часто не випускає дітей на підконтрольну Україну.
Як непросто було виїхати з Донецька, пам'ятає студент-третьокурсник Дмитро.
Це і обшуки, й численні запитання на кордоні.
В Донецьку після закінчення школи Дмитро  два роки навчався в коледжі,
перш ніж зважився всупати в університет у Києві.
Тепер повернутись до рідного Донецька хлопець планує лише тоді,
коли його контролюватиме українська влада.
Мене веселило те, що у нас в місті є міжнародні відносини.
А які міжнародні відносини в "ДНР і ЛНР"?
Донецьку я бачив, як усе тлінно було - через війну,
пелену війну на всіх людях видно.
Щасливих людей там мало було останнім часом.
Щойно переїхав до Києва, відразу помітив,
що тут і люди по вулиці ходять об 11 ночі,
а у нас же там комендантська година була.
І люди посміхаються.
Я  вирішив переїхати, коли зрозумів, що в Донецьку мені, на жаль, робити нічого.
В останні чотири роки, за приблизними оцінками, до українських вузів
на особливих умовах вступили близько п'яти тисяч випускників
з окупованого Донбасу та анексованого Криму.
Значна кількість дітей все ж залишається на окупованій територій
чи їде здобувати освіту в Росію.
Українські освітяни розуміють, що випускники російських вишів
навряд чи будуть в майбутньому прихильниками цілісності України.
владі радять працювати над подальшими механізмами,
які дозволять інтегрувати дітей та молодь з окупованих територій
в українській освітній та культурний простір.